Oh, hello there son.
Dude I used to play magic so much me my brother and my dad got into at the same time
My dad kept going he got to 17th in the state of, Georgia
Impossible into the second part it's never going to happen. I've been wondering how hard it is to catch an arrow, a-la-bow
And we're going to put that to the test
Hey Jake, can I bother you for a second?
Alright, come on, get up. Come on and join me. What do you want me to do with this? I want you to shoot that at me.
Try and hit me. Wait, why are you trying to shoot Niko?
What was that?
So clearly, I'm extremely skilled at it
But if any of you guys think you can do it, or want to train with me, I'm down. Again Jake
Do you think you can catch an arrow?
From Jake? Yeah. I can try...
Impossible into the second part it's never going to happen. So
It'll be like
See if you can shoot it right, Niko
If Wren would have gone for that, it would've worked
Wow. I think you should consider subscribing for that
I think you need to subscribe
I think we need to raise the stakes and we need to have like a blindfolded King
Behind you
And if arrow hits the king they die and you're the bodyguard you just snatch it out of the air you got trained to be
the ultimate soldier
Because this next scene is sponsored by Magic the Gathering
This is the magic gather gathering. This is the gathering
Dude, I used to play magic so much. I still got my old decks, man
I got my deck - My zombie deck right here
Zombies
This was my first - this was my very first magic deck ever
Me and Adrian-
When did you start?
10th edition
Is when I started me my brother and my dad got into at the same time along with a couple friends
I stopped playing like two years later. My dad kept going. He got to 17th in the state of Georgia
He competed like legit. How does it compare to the pokémon card game? Oh, it's so much- better? -better!
It's like it's like chess versus checkers like well, you know, yeah. Yeah, yeah
It's like there's more to do super fun way. Yes, they're coming out with a new thing
Oh, yeah, we're gonna tell you all about it
We have yet again rented an awesome cabin out here in the basically middle of nowhere and we are filming Sam's
Spooky house, AKA turn off
It's so important to start your day with a healthy dose of protein
We have three nights to shoot this video here. Over the course of those three nights we have lots of things.
We have people, we have locations,
we have monsters and...
We have to figure out, "what's the best order to shoot everything in?" There's some technical logistics
and we need to figure out that each time you go to a new location is always about your dreams clashing with reality.
So, you know you go into it imagining one thing and then you get to your location and generally, everything changes.
It's all about trying to adapt that imagination, that idea, into what you actually have before you the best way possible.
So, we're gonna figure that out right now.
Oh, well hello there son.
Welcome to The Adventures of Sam Gorski, directing his fist debut movie.
Oh, it's not? Join us now, as Gorski directs his actors.
Why seeing him like looking of the like doing the shirt Oh
Oh what up son.
Night one in beutiful Ottowa California.
This son's over there, makin' fun of me.
I'm not makin' fun of you son.
Completely shooting in the dark over night shoots, you know, we're looking at 6 p.m. To 2:30 to 3:00 a.m
Nights for three nights in a row. There's a lot of good sons on this shoots, huh?
So I'm looking forward to the shoot. We got Samson. He's got a lot of skills Sam-son
Okay. We also have Riley who's a talented actress. Hi!
I'm Riley Rose Critchlow and I'm playing Alyssa. My name is Gabriel and I'm playing Michael. Gabriel Anthony Paul Michael I forgot my last name.
It's important. Yeah
Everybody's a son though...
Cat, she's a talented makeup artist; effects artist
So yeah, there's a lot of talented people as a matter of fact, we got Jared right here. Jared's a talented son right here
We were talking about Jared earlier. Hmm, and we were saying you've been going from the roof a lot
Yeah, we're a little concerned about that. I can only do it with like half a bottle of wine is
Safety, yeah. Yeah. We're uh see the glaze. Oh, yeah. Okay. All right
We're about to put Jared on the roof Sam has instructed this right, that's correct
Used to mentioned earlier or something about g-string with that we'd be wearing that that's for you. I don't want to wear that though
Yeah, but it's for the audience for them. Not for you. I don't want to wear a g-string though, dude
I mean, it's just you know, it's like flossing, you'll feel it you'll get used to it.
What a weird note. "It's like flossing."
I'm a horror fan. So it's gonna be fun to like dive into that genre for me for sure
I've never done horror either. I've also never brushed my hair like this either too. So that is a challenge. I know but many firsts
First thing in the night definitely a little nervous, but once the wheels of this shoot get goin, it's gonna be all good
I know our first scene here two lovers on a couch and how do we make a look at nights?
Well check this out. The entire video right now is motivated by moonlight the concept of moonlight being the only source of light
This is not normal darkness. This is movie darkness and movie darkness is actually quite bright. So we need lights so
Where do we put them?
well, we want to start with our actual true moonlight, which is effectively just one of those aperture 120 DS that just
Blast some nice hard rays right into the room
We have a little bit of a Heiser in there to kick up some haze and mist which will catch the light
Creating some depth in the scene and also maybe some light rays that look cool
That's not all because when you look into the camera, you'll see that all right, the characters are lit
We have some layers all that stuff, but the room is still surrounded in darkness
So once again movie night, right, what does that look like?
well
We've set up some of the the BH
Proprietary lights what they call the violas point is they're actually pretty great because they're little and they adapt to any color temperature and color
and hue shift
We're using them to create little
splashes of light in the dark areas of the room so that way when you look at the scene
You're not actually looking at like blackness ever. There's always this kind of lift
Well, the light that actually likes the characters faaces is gonna be a phone screen in this scene
So we've cranked the red
We've got some good Sigma lenses on there and hopefully the light sensitivity will carry us the rest of the way
Welcome to Corridor Digital's production of "Turn Off" and uhh, night one.
(Applause )
Let's be safe here. Let's not rush anything and get anybody hurt. Hey everything's set right now and
We can dive into it if everyone's ready. All right
All right, it's time to up the stakes if you missed the arrow. It doesn't just hit a wall it hits a person
All right Chinchin to see who the king is that's gonna stand there blindfolded. Call it Niko. All right, that's right
Today's video is brought to you by our sponsor Magic the Gathering
guilds of Ravnica the 79th
expansion of Magic the Gathering the game now where the guild war imminent the Celestia Conclave one of the guilds of
Ravnica is preparing their armies. The corridor crew has signed on to help them as archers and scouts, obviously because we're super into archery
No, fooling around you gotta catch this arrow. We just have to do the same thing
We had last time wren and stop it like this
To defend our king listen if I die you die, too
I said if I die you die, too
No, It's all up to you man
Best of luck
I thought he was a gonner for sure! Niko I got you, I got you Niko
I wanna shoot, I wanna shoot.
At any moment, this is gonna happen anywhere in your body
You're gonna die Clint
I don't need to do this. I want Jake to protect me. I don't trust either of these two
What? We've proven ourselves twice!
Ready
I'm really scared (Wren)
Did I deflect it? -Wow- slashing prices dude. Not even nervous anymore
Nooooo
Are you okay?
I'm fine - he got my thigh like right there
Right there!
my god
No my king. I get to execute you. I think that's only fair King Joseph, The 16
Your head is mine
Hey, gotcha
aw...
King Joseph the 16 your head will be in my possession
I'm gonna catch it.
(sad music)
Wren that was cruel
Wow ice cold
So that's it. I hope you enjoyed it. Remember Magic the Gathering guilds of Ravnica is on sale, October 5th
Each guild has its own unique style ideology and characters
The Celestia Conclave is one of the most interesting which is why we wanted to do something with it has powerful
Military like aspects combined with almost hippie like commune bods. It's really interesting
also that are unique ideology teaches that
Individuals must be willing to perish so that the greater good may survive kind of like I just did right here
Yo if you see what man that'd be this is that historian occasion
I'm gonna need my glasses for this
Not the Bees, anything but bees (music)
They see right through me They see right through me
Not the Bees...
They see right through me. yeah, they got X-ray vision. Yeah I don't remember how that one went.